Adetola Olatunji: We all realized how much
it affected not only the
people that we knew in the company, but also
our friends, like outside
the company -- on campus and back home. So
we thought it'd be a good
idea to use our dance, and the fact that we
already reach out to people
through our dance to bring the campus together,
to be able to get
involved and help out and give back.
Brittany Kelleher: You know, I'm very fortunate
to be here in the
United States, here in Princeton, and any
opportunity to give back and
to help with the catastrophe that happened,
I'm willing to do.
Adam from diSiaC: It's hard sometimes when
these things happen in the
world and as college students -- it's like
you're kind of you know, like
"how can I possibly help? what can my contribution
mean, or how can it
really be significant?"
Lara Yuan: I thought it was a really great
way to help with the
earthquake. After hearing about it, I wanted
to help in some way, and I
didn't know what the best way would be; and
what better way than to
dance, to do what I love?
Kyle Ofori: To be able to put something that
you uniquely can do
towards a good cause -- it gives you a good
feeling.
Adetola Olatunji: What it means to me to be
able to have my dance
company come together and then have other
dance companies collaborate
with us and be willing to join with us, that's
awesome to see. It
doesn't have to be about what dance company
you're in, or any of that,
we can just forget about all those divides
for now and just come
together. It means a lot to see that our campus
can just really unite
for one cause. It's amazing to see that.
Kyle: I'm Kyle Ofori. I'm a freshman in Highsteppers.
Brittany: My name is Brittany Kelleher, and
I am the artistic director
for BodyHype.
Lara: [laughs] I'm Lara Yuan, and I'm with
eXpressions.
Adam: My name's Adam, and I'm in diSiaC.
Adetola: I'm Adetola Olatunji and I'm artistic
director of BAC.
[Music]